bonjour à tous très heureuse de vous
retrouver sur publ Sénat pour une
nouvelle après-midi de direct au
sommaire à 16h35 juste après ce journal
direction l'hémicycle pour un débat sur
la liberté de la presse à 18h15 vous
retrouvez épreuve par 3 et notre grand
débat de l'entre de tour et bien sûr à
19h c'est votre journal 24h Sénat
présenté par Delphine Girard mais avant
de commencer avec l'actualité politique
du Sénat le tragique accident de
l'Airbus à à 320 les sénateurs viennent
d'observer une minute de silence et
l'ordre du jour a été modifié Alain
vidalis le secrétaire d'État au
transport ne pourra pas assister aux
deux débats prévus sur l'aéronautique et
les huîres ces débats sont donc reportés
sinédié au Sénat toujours le déjeuner
entre Gérard Larché et Jean-Marie
legouen au menu la réforme du travail
parlementaire je vous propose d'écouter
le secrétaire d'État chargé des
relations avec le Parlement nous allons
en discuter c'est bien logique que les
deux
assemblées cherche à à à faire valoir le
travail de contrôle et en même temps il
faut que le gouvernement puisse
travailler aussi de façon
sereine on envent maintenant au débat du
jour au Sénat un débat sur la liberté de
la presse et j'accueille pour nous
expliquer les enjeux de cette question
Faustine saint jeuniè Faustine les
sénateurs vont surtout se pencher sur
les débordem de cette liberté
d'expression sur Internet c'est bien ça
oui après les attentats meurtriers de
janvier dernier on a constaté les
pouvoirs publics se sont retrouvés
complètement démuni complètement désarmé
face au débordement sur internet on peut
citer pelmel l'incitation à la haine
raciale l'apologie des idées de l'État
islamique ou encore la multiplication de
sites servant au recrutement de
terroriste plus que jamais après le
après le le mois de janvier on s'est
rendu compte qu'Internet était un espace
de liberté sans frontières mais un
espace aussi de débordement c'est le
constat dressé par les sénateurs du
groupe des Radicaux de Gauche ici au
Sénat qui sont à l'initiative de ce
débat le débat est simple comment
adapter la loi du 29 juillet 1881 sur la
liberté de la presse au défi posé par
internet mais attention en respectant
l'esprit de cette loi un esprit
d'affranchissement et de liberté comme
son nom l'indique et ici au Sénat on a
deux camps qui s'affrontent si j'ose
dire il y a le camp qui voit dans
Internet un espace s fois nois et un
camp peut-être un peu plus nuancé un peu
plus progressiste qui voit un espace de
liberté de richesse mais attention pour
eux il est hors de question que ce soit
un espace d'impunité merci fustine et
tout de suite donc direction la séance
pour ce
débat l'ordre du
jour appelle le débat sur le thème
Internet et la loi du 29 juillet
1881 sur la liberté de la presse demande
du groupe
RDSE la parole est tout d'abord à
l'orateur du groupe qui a demandé ce
débat Monsieur Jacques mard au nom du
groupe
RDSE vous avez la parole monsieur le
président
monsieur le
Président Madame la ministre mes chers
collègues difficile d'avoir des débats
entre deux tours d'élection il n'en
reste pas moins que le débat que nous
avons
proposé nous paraît un débat important
et sur lequel il est tout à fait
souhaitable que des décisions soient
prises dans les mois qui viennent de la
couverture par les médias des drames de
janvier pour laquelle d'ailleurs le
Conseil supérieur de l'audiovisuel a
relevé 36 manquements justifiant des
mises en
demeure à la multiplication des messages
d'apologie du terrorisme sur les réseaux
sociaux les dérives et incertitudes
pesant sur la liberté d'expression ont
été mis à jour acquis démocratique
majeur la liberté d'expression sert
aujourd'hui de parapluie nucléaire à
toutes sortes d'idées et de
manipulation lieu de
sociabilité les réseaux
dissociaux sont souvent détournés et
sont parfois devenus des lieux de
perdition pour une partie de notre
jeunesse en servant de relais à la
propagande djihadiste ou encore aux
théories cons
conspirationnistes et à l'heure du
numérique
la rumeur
F est devenue infemme et gangrainene nos
valeurs et notre confiance en la
puissance publique en esséant son poison
de manière
exponentielle face à
cela face aussi à au dévoiement de la
théorie du complot d'ailleurs dont la
ministre de l'Éducation nationale a
parlé à juste titre il y a quelques
semaines plusieurs condamnations pour
l'exemple ont été prononcées à
l'encontre individus ayant fait
l'apologie du terrorisme sur les réseaux
mais selon une étude publiée début mars
entre 46000 et 90000 comptes Twitter ont
été utilisés à l'automne dernier pour
diffuser la propagande de l'État
islamique un travail herculéen pour nos
services de police et de renseignement
transformé en
cisif la liberté d'expression pharmacone
démocratique contient en elle-même à la
fois son poison et son
médicament de nombreux textes nationaux
et internationaux la protègent l'article
11 de la Déclaration des Droits de
l'Homme et du Citoyen auquel nous sommes
nous notre groupe profondément attaché
l'arrange parmi les droits je cite les
droits les plus précieux de l'homme au
fondement même de nos démocraties
libérales mais cette liberté comme toute
la liberté s'arrête là où celle des
autres tout citoyen peut donc parler
écrire imprimer librement sauf à
répondre de l'abus de cette liberté or
si les textes limitant la liberté
d'expression s'appliquent de plein droit
à l'expression sur Internet leur
efficacité pose aujourd'hui question la
loi de 2004 a étendu aux éditeurs de
servicees de communication au public en
ligne le chapitre 4 de la loi de 81 qui
punit notamment la provocation au CRIM
et délits en particulier la provocation
à la discrimination ou à la haine en
raison de l'origine de la religion ou de
l'orientation sexuelle mais c'est plus
radicalement encore qu'Internet
redéfinit les contours de la liberté
d'expression tant pour les journalistes
que pour les simples citoyens en rendant
Cadu certains moyens d'intervention des
pouvoirs publics voter sous la trème
République celle là même à laquelle nous
devons et nous tenons tant la loi de
1881 avait était conçu comme une loi
d'affranchissement et de liberté
elle révolutionnait la logique des
textes précédents qui prévoyit des
systèmes de contrôle préalable
d'autorisation et de censure jusqu'à
l'émergence d'Internet il y avait une
parfaite superposition entre la forme
d'expression le moyen technique employé
et le régime juridique la presse
diffusée sous la forme de journaux
imprimés et régis par la loi de 81 la
communication téléphonique régie par le
code des postes C télécommunication
enfin la communication audiovisuelle
régie par la loi du 30 septembre 86
l'émergence d'Internet qui a démultiplié
à l'infini l'information a remis en
cause ces distinctions traditionnelles
puisqu'il permet de diffusé par le même
médium des contenus relevant de la
correspondance privée de la presse et de
l'audiovisuel ces spécificités
conduisent donc à s'interroger d'une
part sur ce qui relève pour les
journalistes et citoyens du droit à
l'information d'autre part sur
l'efficacité des mesures prises par les
pouvoirs publics à l'encontre des
contenus illicites et la protection des
personnes privées est pour nous quelque
chose de très important nous connaissons
nous élus les attaques sous sous
pseudonyme jusqu'à quand va-t-on tolérer
tout n'importe quoi et dans n'importe
quel conditions en ce qui concerne plus
particulièrement les contenus illicites
nous avions eu ce débat lors de l'examen
en novembre de la loi visant à renforcer
la lutte contre le terrorisme les délis
de provocation à la commission d'actes
terroristes et d'apologie du terrorisme
ont été transf transférés de la loi de
81 vers le code pénal ce transfert a été
effectué au motif que ces actes ne
constittu plus essentiellement un abus
de la liberté d'expression mais plutôt
un maillon dans la chaîne des activités
des groupes terroristes ce qui
permettait aussi d'exercer des
poursuites en dehors du régime
procédural contraignant et donc
protecteur de la liberté d'expression de
la loi de
81 faut-il considérer que l'intégralité
des infractions commise par le biais
d'Internet et des réseaux sociaux doit
être soumise à un régime dérogatoire à
la loi de 1881 c'est un vrai débat c'est
un débat qui est urgent nous ne le
résoudrons pas aujourd'hui mais il
importe d'aller rapidement vers des
solutions respectueuse de la liberté
mais de la liberté aussi de
chacun à tout le le moins faudra-t-il
que le législateur s'empare sans embâ de
ces problématiques touchant au numérique
de manière systématique et sectorielle
une autre question est celle du rôle des
acteurs d'Internet la loi pour la
confiance en l'économie numérique de
2004 a créé un régime marqué par une
grande liberté des acteurs d'Internet à
la différence du régime de la
communication audiovisuelle l'édition
d'un contenu numérique n'est pas soumise
à autorisation préalable aucune
obligation n'est priori imposé aux
fournisseurs de contenus deux catégories
d'acteurs sont définis premièrement les
éditeurs de services sur Internet soumis
à un régime voisin de celui de la presse
aucune obligation de déclaration
préalable d'autorisation seulle limite à
leur liberté d'expression celle définie
par le chapitre 4 de la loi de 81 ces
infractions étant poursuivies et
réprimées et ils doivent désigner un
directeur de publication avec un droit
de réponse qui est prévu par la loi qui
transpose à Internet le régime de
l'article 13 de la loi de 81 les
hébergeurs 2e catégorie d'acteurs
bénéficient d'un régime de
responsabilité civile et pénal atténué
par rapport à celui des éditeurs ils
sont regardés comme n'exerçant pas de
contrôle sur les contenus accessibles
par leur site et donc avec une
responsabilité très difficile à engager
la loi de novembre 2014 a étendu le
champ d'application des obligation des
fournisseurs d'accès et des hébergeurs
en matière de signalement des contenus
illicites elle a en outre créé une
possib de blocage administratif des
sites internet faisant l'apologie du
terrorisme les premiers blocages vous le
savez mes chers collègues ont eu lieu il
y a quelques jours non sans quelques
difficulté prévisible du fait notamment
de l'absence de contrôle par le juge ce
blocage ne fut que partiel certains
opérateurs français non des moindres
n'ont pas appliqué le dispositif du
gouvernement par ailleurs de nombreuses
stratégies de contournement existent
permettant à certains internautes et au
propagandiste de jouer au chat et à la
souris avec les pouvoirs publics liberté
d'expression contre censure l'opposition
simpliste brandi par une certaine
propagande et flatteuse pour ceux qui se
réclament de la
première la domiciliation de beaucoup
d'acteurs d'Internet à l'étranger
compliquent encore toute action si
certains réseaux sociaux comme Twitter
ont défendu une conception radicalement
libérale de liberté d'expression avec la
doctrine freedom of speech et je
n'utilise pas souvent les termes anglais
l'idée se fait jour qu'une trop grande
liberté d'expression est une manière de
se cacher derrière ses
responsabilités l'accès aux vidéos
insoutenable diffusé sur Internet qui
vise à enrôler de nouveaux djihadistes
glorifiant les terroristes les filmants
exécutant leurs victimes fait-il
légitimement partie de la liberté
d'expression avec plus d'un milliard
d'utilisateurs pour Facebook et
plusieurs centaines de millions pour
Twitter les grande plateforme du web se
retrouvent arbitre de la liberté
d'expression et doivent assumer leur
rôle si les pouvoirs publics peuvent
inciter les plateformes à mettre en
œuvre des mesures de surveillance
générale des contenus cette intervention
d'acteurs privés pose des questions
quant à sa légitimité peut-on parler de
privatisation de l'exécution de la loi
pour nous c'est
inacceptable le départ entre le droit à
l'excès à l'outrance et à la parodie à
des fins humoristiques d'un côté et
l'apologie au terrorisme d'un autre côté
devra-t-il être fait par les acteurs
privés dans ce combat un peu de David
contre Goliath à l'air numérique le juge
français a ainsi dû déterminer si le
fait qu'un site accessible depuis la
France offre un contenu en infraction
avec le droit pénal français suffisait à
considérer que l'infraction a été
commise sur le territoire nos
juridictions pénales ont d'abord
considéré que l'accessibilité du site
internet suffisait à fonder la
compétence du juge français or la Cour
de cassation juge à l'inverse
aujourd'hui que le site internet en
cause doit être destiné au public
français pour que le juge pénal soit
compétent récemment le TGI de Paris a
déclaré abusive une clause de compétence
signé par les utilisateurs de Facebook
et précisant qu'en cas de litige seul un
tribunal de Californie où est domicile
réseau social et compétent mes chers
collègues nous ne prétendrons pas
apporter de solution à une réalité
protéif forme et sans cesse mouvante non
seulement les États sont fondés à à
réglementer internet mais ils ont la
capacité et plus que jamais le devoir de
le faire la logique répressive ne doit
pas éluder la question de la prévention
de la radicalisation et de l'éducation
des esprits et la critique l'école de la
République fondée sur la maxime sapéré
od ose savoir doit sensibiliser au
nouveaux dangers d'Internet la la
capacité d'intervention des États doit
ainsi être utilisée en amont comme en
aval pour combiner notre passion de la
liberté avec le sens de la
responsabilité mes chers collègues comme
jadisent les pères fondateurs de la
République comme notre prédécesseur ici
même en 1881 eux qui ignoraient
l'existence future d'Internet et des
réseaux sociaux il nous faut trouver et
vite le juste équilibre entre la liberté
d'expression sur intern
nécessaire et la responsabilité assumer
des paroles des écrits et des actes de
chacun car il n'est pas concevable qu'on
puisse continuer à écrire à dire
n'importe quoi à provoquer à susciter le
terrorisme avec les conséquen que l'on
sait ce débat que nous avons voulu nous
le groupe RDSE n'a d'autre objectif que
d'entamer la réflexion pour trouver cet
équilibre indispensable cet équilibre
qui nous permettra de nous protéger des
ennemis de la liberté et de la
démocratie sans porter atteinte aux
liberté d'opinion et d'expression qui
sont au fondement de l'idéal
démocratique et de la tradition radicale
merci je vous remercie monsieur le
Président dans la suite du débat la
parole est à Madame Catherine main de
sailli pour le groupe udi hussier pour 8
minutes
monsieur le Président madamees les
ministres mes chers collègues internet
promesse d'une liberté d'expression sans
frontières est-il en passe de devenir un
outil de surveillance sans limite je
choisis de poser ainsi les termes de
notre débat sur Internet et la liberté
de la presse qu'il convient de ne pas
confondre avec la liberté d'expression
dont jouit l'ensemble des citoyens
depuis la loi de juillet 1881 la France
protège par une législation AD ces
journalistes auxquels elle assure un
exercice libre de leur profession et la
protection de leurs sources en
contre-partie du respect de certaines
interdictions visant à garantir la
fiabilité et l'honorabilité des
informations diffusées provocation à la
violence et à la haine publication de
faux diffamation et injure diffusion
d'informations sur une procédure
judiciaire en cours violation du droit à
l'image notamment 5 siècles après
gutimberg et moins de 100 ans après
l'invention du tube cathodique ces
règles demeure même si l'émergence du
numérique a révolutionné les modalités
de partage de l'information de la
vitesse de diffusion à la facilité
d'accès au contenu Internet a
profondément ébranlé le modèle
économique de la presse l'a obligé de se
réinventé face à de nouvelles
concurrences comme il en bouleverse bien
sûr aussi les méthodes de travail au
côté des organes traditionnels une
multitude de journalistes indépendants
et de blogueurs citoyens a émergé
proposant au monde une information
nouvelle dans des conditions parfois
périlleuses en particulier en provenance
de pays où la presse traditionnelle
peine à œuvrer librement je citerai
l'exemple de l'Iran ou sous
l'administration du président ahadinjad
un grand nombre de reporters et de
chroniqueurs de renom de la presse
écrite se sont tournés pour éviter la
censure vers Internet contribuant à
l'édification de la blogosphère farci
depuis 2010 le rapport annuel du Comité
pour la protection des journalistes
faisant état des journalistes incarcérés
de par le monde estime que plus de la
moitié de ceux qui ont été privés de
parole étai publiés sur le Web si
Internet représente une opportunité pour
la presse il constitue aussi pour elle
une menace les événements tragiques du
mois de janvier ont rappelé combien la
diffusion planétaire d'une information
rendait nos journalistes vulnérables
jusque dans un pays chantre de la
liberté de la presse et de la liberté
d'opinion mais ne nous y trompons pas la
menace que j'évoque ne se limite pas au
danger si grand soit-il que les émis de
la liberté font peser sur ceux qui
défendent un exercice pleinement
indépendant du journalisme d'information
et d'opinion elle peut-être également
institutionnelle et politique lorsque
les États au nom de la sécurité
multiplient les systèmes de surveillance
alors bien sûr nos démocraties ne
censurent ni n'intimid ou n'emprisonne
les journalistes comme ell n'empêche pas
davantage l'échange d'information entre
citoyens en multipliant les restrictions
techniques sur la toile il n'ont de Meur
pas moins que de légitimes
interrogations se font jour dès lors
qu'Internet semble devenir un redoutable
outil de surveillance en facilitant le
stockage et le traitement le Big Data a
de fait incité une collecte
exponentielle de données notamment
personnel exploité tant par les géants
du Net que par les services de
renseignement comme l'affaire snowon l'a
amplement révélé jusqu'à présent la
France semblait protégée de tels abus
quen sera-t-il demain ainsi pour
l'application de l'article 20 de la loi
du 18 décembre 2013 relative à la
programmation militaire le gouvernement
a discrètement pris le 24 décembre
dernier un décret relatif à l'accès
administratif aux données de connexion
or cet article qui autorise l'obtention
de données personnelles et la
surveillance des communications
téléphoniques et internet en temps réel
par l'administration porte atteinte à la
vie privée des citoyens comme à la
liberté d'information et au secret des
sources on peut y relever trois motifs
d'inquiétude l'absence de contrôle du
juge pendant la procédure de mise sous
surveillance des objectifs fort large
justifiant la surveillance et un spectre
très étendu des données recueillies
reporter sans frontière a déposé le 24
février un recours en annulation du
décret devant le Conseil d'État notre
commission de la culture l'éducation et
de la communication prendra connaissance
avec intérêt de sa décision en la
matière le projet de loi relatif au
renseignement pose également question
dans son avis publié mercredi la
Commission nationale de l'informatique
et des libertés déplorer la présence
dans le projet de loi de mesures de
surveillance beaucoup plus large et
intrusive que celle autorisée par
l'actuelle législation citant notamment
la possibilité de collecter de manière
indifférenciée un volume important de
données qui peuvent être relatives à des
personnes tout à fait étrangèr à la
mission de renseignement le Conseil
National du Numérique a pour sa part
manifester son inquiétude au
gouvernement quant à l'extension
significative du périmètre de la
surveillance prévu par le projet de loi
selon des critères jugés flous la
prévention contre les vololances
collectives et la défense des intérêts
de la politique étrangère je partage les
craintes exprimées par ces deux
institutions dont chacun connaît ici la
compétence et l'indépendance de vue le
risque de surveillance de masse existe
et il nous concerne tous mais plus
encore les journalistes dont l'anonymat
des sources pourrait ne plus t être
garanti je ne ni nullement les
impératifs de protection de la société
qui incombe à l'état plus
particulièrement en cé tempant troublé
par la perpétuelle menace des attaques
terroristes et la nécessité dans ce
cadre de mettre en œuvre des dispositifs
de lutte contre la violence et la
propagande sur Internet j'alerte aussi
sur une potentielle dérive que les
outils mis en place pourrai faire peser
sur la liberté de la presse bien sûr
cette liberté doit continuer de jouir
dont doit continuer de jouir tout
journaliste bien ne peut faire bien sûr
l'économie de la déontologie de
l'information parfois la recherche du
scoop à tout prix fait oublier
l'indispensable vérification des
informations souvenez-vous de l'annonce
erronée du décès de Martin big par l'AFP
récemment les journalistes doivent être
responsabilisés mais également
identifiés en tant que tel sur le web
afin que l'internaute puisse juger
aisément de la fiabilité d'une
information à cet égard l'équilibre
économique des organes de presse en
ligne constitue un enjeu majeur pour
garantir dans la durée la diffusion
d'une information professionnelle de
qualité au sein d'une myriade de sites
et de blogs amateurs un équilibre juste
doit donc être trouvé entre liberté et
sécurité il est à cet égard
indispensable que les dispositifs de
sécurité sur Internet tiennent compte de
l'originalité du métier de journaliste
et notamment de la nécessaire protection
des sources la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme ne dit pas autre chose
lorsque sa jurisprudence rappelle
régulièrement que les États membres du
Conseil de l'Europe ont l'obligation de
créer un cas normatif permettant
d'assurer la protection efficace de la
liberté d'expression des journalistes
sur Internet et plus largement de
l'ensemble de leurs concitoyens ainsi
dans son premier arrêt portant sur le
blocage de l'accès au Web rendu en
décembre 2012 elle a conclu à la
violation par la Turquie de l'article 10
de la la Convention européenne des
droits de l'homme relatif à la liberté
d'expression estimant notamment que les
mesures limitant l'accès à des contenus
sur Internet doivent se fonder sur une
loi suffisamment précise et être
accompagné d'un contrôle juridictionnel
prenons garde à ce que notre propre
législation ne s'éloigne pas de ces
principes la France ne doit pas renier
l'esprit de la loi de 1881 comme elle
doit demeurer fidèle à ses engagements
internationaux en faveur de la liberté
des expression et de la liberté de la
presse rappelons qu'il y a moins d'un an
au mois de mai 2014 nous avions
activement soutenu l'adoption par
l'Union européenne de lignes directrices
pour les droits de l'homme consacré à la
liberté d'expression en ligne et hors
ligne il convient d'éviter donc à mon
sens les distinctions artificielles dans
l'exercice des libertés d'information et
d'expression en fonction du support de
diffusion des contenus le caractère
diffus d'Internet ne doit en aucun cas
servir de prétexte à l'instauration de
nouvelles limitations en matière des
droits de l'homme et de liberté
fondamentales notamment le droit de
recevoir et de communiquer des
informations il incombe donc madame la
ministre à l'état de protéger ses
libertés comme celle des journalistes à
exercer leur métier en toute
indépendance à cette effet au-delà de la
législation applicable un dialogue est
indispensable avec les autres acteurs de
la gouvernance d'Internet y compris les
grandes entreprise du numérique sans
quoi la garantie d'une libre circulation
des informations sur Internet et de la
proportionnalité des mesures de
restriction qui parfois s'impos ne
pourront être effectives je vous
remercie de votre attention merci madame
la
Présidente la parole est à Monsieur
Pierre
Charon pour 7
minutes monsieur le président président
madame la ministre mes chers
collègues lorsqu'Internet est né le
monde s'émerveillait il était la
promesse d'un espace d'échange
d'information de communication et même
d'éducation en réalité internet est une
perpétuelle révolution pour l'humanité
Internet est surtout la promesse d'un
espace de liberté absolu
s'affranchissant de toutes les
frontières qu'elle soit géographique
juridique voire morale pour la presse
internet un outil essentiel et une
promesse de développement en particulier
dans les pays où la liberté d'expression
est bafouée par ailleurs à cet instant
parmettez-moi de rendre hommage à tous
les journalistes qui parfois risquent
leur vie pour exercer leur métier en
2015 soit plus de 30 ans après sa
création internet offre au monde un
autre visage celui d'un espace sans fois
ni loi permettant la diffusion du pire
de ce que l'humanité a pu produire
Internet favorise l'expression de tous
peu importe leur opinion et leurs
croyances aujourd'hui le pire a atteint
son paroxisme aujourd'hui les islamistes
les plus radicaux ont épousé le projet
politique d'instaurer un califat mondial
assassinant quiconque s'y opposerait
mais l'état islamique mène aussi une
autre guerre dont le théâtre ne connaît
pas de frontières à cause d'Internet il
bénéficie d'une existence médiatique
sans limite dès lors internet n'est plus
un simple moyen de communication c'est
une sphère d'expansion inouï où les
propagandes les plus fanatiques peuvent
être disylées en toute légitimité pire
internet est un sergent recruteur aussi
discret qu'efficace comme en témoigne le
nombre de jeunes Français partis faire
le djihad c'est un outil de
radicalisation et de recrutement pour
terroristes en herbe mais internet est
aussi la sphère d'une tragique émulation
d'une macabre concurrence entre
mouvances terroristes lors de la tuie de
Charlie hebbdo l'un des auteurs de ce
crime affreux n'a pas hésité à faire la
publicité de son appartenance à Al-Qaïda
au Yémen la diffusion des vidéos
insoutenables et la mise en scène des
exécutions des otages sont des exemples
de cette ignoble politique de
communication dès lors internet est une
couveuse pour apprenti terroriste un
vivier pour les ennemis de la liberté
qui est pourtant l'un des fondement de
notre République aujourd'hui Internet
est un nouveau théâtre d'opération dans
notre lutte contre le terrorisme ne nous
y trompons pas l'objectif des
terroristes est de mettre à l'épreuve
les démocraties dans ce qu'elles ont de
plus cher l'attache au liberté publique
la liberté de la presse en est l'un des
fleurons oui elle est une conquête une
belle conquête notamment à Chevé sous la
3e république par sa grande charte qui
est la loi du 29 juillet 1881 mais elle
reste fragile aujourd'hui celle-ci est
détourné siamment la problématique est
claire comment concilier ce précieux
acquis de la loi de
1881 et la diffusion de publications
glorifiant le génocide des chrétiens
d'Orient et des yésidistes en Irak la
instruction de lieux de culte et des
autodffet de livres ancestraux
pouvons-nous laisser fleurir et
prospérer sur Internet au nom de cette
liberté ce type de littérature dont les
atours sont les mêmes que nos magazines
électroniques il s'agit de dépasser ce
piège intellectuel qui tend à opposer
liberté et sécurité on ne peut glorifier
la liberté jusqu'à la déraison notre
responsabilité est de comprendre les
enjeux du terrorisme et d'y répondre
sans nous renier ainsi la vraie question
dépasse la seule liberté de la presse
sur Internet la vraie question c'est la
gouvernance d'Internet et les actions
que peuvent mener tant les responsables
politiques que les grands acteurs du net
de fait je veux saluer l'initiative de
Monsieur casazenu qui s'est entretenu
avec les représentants des géants du Net
que sont Facebook et Google en France
des mesures pour bloquer les sites
internet faisant l'apologie du
terrorisme ont été adopté et je m'en
réjouis c'est un signe fort envoyé à nos
concitoyens mais aussi aux terroristes
le Web ne rime pas avec impunité c'est
aussi la preuve que nous prenons ainsi
notre part de responsabilité sur
internet il n'est pas envisageable que
les publications de l'État islamique en
langue française téléchargeable par
simple clic puissent être à la portée de
tous et en particulier des plus jeunes
néanmoins une autre question se pose
pour nos services de renseignement ces
publications et ces sites nous
permettent aussi de remonter des
filières entières pouvant démontrer les
connexions entre les différents réseaux
supprimer ces sites et empêcher la
diffusion de ces publications ne
nuirait-il pas au final à nos services
je ne le crois pas pour cela il importe
que nos agents disposent de toutes les
ressources techniques et logistiques en
outre l'action de la France ne peut-être
isolée c'est une politique européenne à
minima mais aussi mondiale qui doit être
mise en place souvenons-nous que tous
les supports d'information peuvent être
utilisés à de mauvaises fins le génocide
rwandais a été insufflé par par les
ondes d'une radio si la radio a pu
servir d'instrument de destruction il en
va de même pour internet n'importe quel
support peut véhiculer la haine nous ne
pouvons nous abriter derrière la liberté
de la presse derrière la loi de 1881
pour justifier notre passivité la
liberté de la presse est au service de
l'homme de sa dignité de sa conscience
elle n'est pas au service de sa
destruction et de ses dessins niilistes
donner aux terroristes l'accès à cette
liberté ce n'est plus défendre la
liberté c'est la confier à des faux
soyeurs nous devons être vigilants car
nous avons vu que tout est bon pour
radicaliser des jeunes ont succombé à la
violence et au djihad par l'exploration
et la lecture de sites leur voyage
virtuelle a ainsi débouché sur une
violence réelle notre arsenal
législatif doit donc être adapté et
modernisé plus généralement soyons
vigilant la responsabilité n'est pas la
censure car la liberté est inséparable
de la dignité humaine n'attendons pas ne
nous laissons pas avoir par des
querelles ou sous prétexte de défendre
la liberté nous finirions par la
détruire ne laissons pas les libertés
devenir l'instrument de leur propre
disparition je récuse toute
contradiction qui nous empêcherait
justement de combattre le terrorisme au
nom du respect de la liberté de la
presse aussi je soutiens avec le groupe
UMP toute initiative sérieuse qui défend
une liberté responsable une liberté
vigilante et non une liberté à genoux
enfin je ne doute pas que lors de
l'examen de la loi sur le renseignement
nous serons au rendez-vous nous serons
créés les conditions de sauvegarde de la
liberté de la presse et de la loi de
1881 qui nous est si chère pour la
concilier avec une autre liberté celle
de vivre en sécurité je vous remercie
merci mon cher collègue la parole est à
David Assouline pour le groupe
socialiste et pour 10
minutes monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers
collègues nous sommes dans un débat
fondamental il touche
à nos valeurs universelles et notamment
une pilier de la République une valeur
historique éthique de la démocratie qui
est la liberté
d'expression c'est aussi un débat
contemporain puisque dans notre
tradition parle la
France c'est d'avoir
arrimé cette liberté d'expression à la
législation sur la presse et à cette loi
fondatrice de
1881 c'est français mais tout le droit
qui régit la liberté d'expression en
France est arrimé à cette loi mais aussi
c'est un débat
moderne puisque la révolution numérique
a complètement transformer les
conditions et les possibilités
d'expression et de communication et a
donc percuté de plein fouet la presse on
peut parler de son équilibre de son
modèle économique le métier de
journaliste mais aussi sa place
spécifique dans la fabrication et la
transmission
d'information au regard de la
possibilité nouvelle pour
chacun à travers les réseaux sociaux et
le net en général de s'exprimer sans
retenue tout en bénéficiant de
l'encadrement législatif permettant de
protéger de façon spécifique les
journalistes et c'est qui a le sujet
c'est qu'une
loi qui a été faite à un moment donné où
l'essentiel de la liberté d'expression
son véhicule était la presse le papier
l'imprimerie
aujourd'hui
bénéficie à tout citoyen qui n'a
absolument
aucune contrainte entre guillemets ou
aucune formation ou aucune
responsabilité qui doit être celle du
journaliste qui est encadré quand même
par un code de déontologie même si
là-dessus il faudrait peut-être
renforcer cet aspect là mais c'est à la
profession de
s'organiser donc c'est là la difficulté
dans ce débat donc qui est difficile car
il s'agit de la liberté d'expression qui
est un bien précieux qu'il faut
préserver défendre sans relâche et sans
compromis et encore moins
mission et je veux là dire que pas de
poids de
mesure la liberté de la presse les
premiers qui on ont eu à pâtir dans
notre pays de façon violentes il y a pas
longtemps c'est
Charlie où on est venu d'abord attaquer
la liberté d'expression à travers un
organe de presse et tout cela a été
préparé par une autre soi-disante
liberté d'expression qui était de
mélanger et de dire que Charlie Hebdo
stigmatisé
était limite avec les questions du
racisme et cetera ou stigmatiser une
population les mêmes pour ça qu'on est
dans un débat
compliqué qui disait pourquoi on
sanctionne Dieu donné et qui considère
que la liberté d'expression c'est la
liberté d'être
raciste et on a assisté à un
retournement Dieu donné c'est la liberté
d'expression et Charlie Hebdo qui n'est
absolument pas dans le racisme mais dans
la caricature et dans la stigmatisation
qu' a toujours eu la moquerie envers les
religions et dans la liberté
d'expression bon ça nous fait aller dans
beaucoup de débat à la fois mais je veux
dire dire que il ne faut pas alimenter
les
confusions la
liberté d'expression doit être
garantie nous devons la défendre la
liberté de la presse aussi et en même
temps la meilleure façon de la défendre
c'est de recadrer le
débat et de s'attaquer à aux dents
creuses je dirais qu'il y a dans notre
législation
apparu avec la révolution de
l'Internet
notamment la réglementation sur la
presse sur Internet n'est pas nouveau en
98 le Conseil d'État nous fournissait
une étude complet dans laquelle il
estimait que l'ensemble de la
législation avait vocation à s'appliquer
aux acteurs d'Internet et notamment
celle qui garantit l'ordre publi c'est
une affirmation il s'agit d'une allusion
à la pierre angulaire de notre droit de
la presse c'est-à-dire la loi du de 81
auquel le débat fait référence cette loi
pose deux principes qui sont dans la
continuité de la Déclaration des droits
de l'homme de
1789 la presse est libre mais cette
liberté est encadrée par des principes
qui évite les abus c'est-à-dire la
diffamation l'injure notamment plus tard
s'attachant à épouser l'évolution de
notre société le législateur a puni la
discrimination avec une loi Pléven en 72
ou le négationnisme des crimes perpétrés
par le régime nazi avec la loi guesso du
13 juillet 90 notre droit ne punit pas
la libre expression il limite
l'expression qui enferme divise se
déploie avec la volonté de s'attaquer au
pacte républicain donc il n'y a pas de
liberté d'expression sans limite qui
n'est pas encadré par les principes qui
font de la
République il évite donc en cela
ce serait pas bon de verser dans ce
domaine dans ce que l'on fait parfois
dans l'économie le libéralisme a tout
craint c'est la même idéologie
d'ailleurs il évite que le journalisme
retourne ses armes contre
lui-même et ce faisant il prend acte de
certaines dérives qu'a connu déjà la
presse l'affaire Salang gros à la mise
en ligne de texte vidéo aujourd'hui qui
remettent en cause notre histoire ou
organise une conérrence mémorielle qui
n'a pas lieu d'être les théories
conspirationnistes et dans l'univers
d'Internet le fait que puisque tout le
monde peut même trafiquer des images
faire des montages et cetera et bien
l'expression qui va venir d'un média
avec des journaliste professionnel est
mis au même niveau que l'expression de
n'importe qui qui a ses moyens
techniques et de là plus aucune
information n'est fiable donc toutes les
théories du complot sont à l'œuvre et
sont t m au même niveau ont la même
valeur informative et c'est là-dessus
plus les élites sont contestées plus les
politiques les journalistes sont remis
en question et on voit ce terreot avec
le populisme dans d'autres sphères de la
société et bien plus on va considérer
même que ce qui va venir d'un média est
moins crédible et prête à
suspicion beaucoup plus que celle qui va
venir dans un citoyen anonyme caché
derrière on ne sait quoi pour diffuser
de l'information alors on ne peut pas
rester les bras croisés et depuis euh
euh il y a eu d'autres euh avancé de la
législation notamment la loi création
internet en 2009 euh au terme de cette
loi l'éditeur est pleinement responsable
des informations publiées sur son site à
l'instar de ce qui existe pour la presse
écrite mais il bénéficie d'un régime
atténué par des par les contributions
personnelles de ces lecteurs comme les
débats sur les articles et les réactions
des lecteurs hélas ces forums sont vite
devenus les viviers de du n'importe quoi
on ne peut pas réguler et donc très
souvent ces forums quand les sites
d'information sont responsables sont
fermés parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas
modérer et donc on a vu là encore la
limite de cette liberté d'expression et
de cette possibilité pour t citoyens de
participer au débat et à la fabrication
de l'information alors il y a le
problème des sites qui choisissent de se
localis à l'étranger des collègues qui
l'ont évoqué les hébergeurs sont trop
longs à réagir et encore quand ils le
font le gouvernement notamment avec ce
qui a été décidé par rapport au sitite
promouvant l'idéologie dihadiste le mois
dernier avec la loi sur le terrorisme a
a commencé à apporter des réponses il y
a la responsabilité des tenant des
réseaux sociaux et y compris des
hébergeurs et des fournisseurs d'accès
il faut qu'il soit plein
responsabilisé et et que ils réagissent
de façon plus efficace et plus directe
pour cela puisqu'ils font des marges
énormes en terme de de de bénéfice
aujourd'hui on peut pas dire que ce sont
eux qui sont soumis aux restrictions
économiques on peut dire que ils doivent
absolument mettre les moyens financiers
humain pour cette régulation et pour
cette réactivité et arrêter de
considérer que c'est qu'un aspect
secondaire de leur propre responsabilité
alors je veux finir en disant que nous
sommes dans un débat très sensible bien
entendu rien n'est évident mais il ne
faudrait pas dans ce domaine tomber dans
deux panneaux et je pense que les
républicains vont devoir trouver le le
chemin au milieu de deux travers le
premier c'est la
solution de limiter la liberté
d'expression et ses potentialités voire
même atteindre au à la liberté de la
presse parce qu'il y a effectivement ces
possibilités inouï aujourd'hui et en
voulant taper ceux qui promovent le
racisme antisémitisme diihadisme et bien
sanctionner l'ensemble de la société ses
capacités d'expression et limiter et
donner un regard négatif à quelque chose
qui est très contradictoire euh
l'internet c'est pas on n pas dire c'est
le pire des trucs j'ai entendu ou c'est
le meilleur des trucs pour ceux qui il
voi franchement l'imprimerie c'était
génial mais on pouvait aussi imprimer
des j'allais dire des j'allais dire un
gros mot mais des des choses ignobles et
diffuser grâce à l'imprimerie des choses
ignobles mais aussi éveiller les esprits
et permettre vraiment des avancées tout
à fait considérables dans le domaine de
la pensée de la science la télé on nous
a dit ah c'est un truc d'abétissement et
mais on a vu aussi les potentialités
gigantesques le net ça va être la même
chose donc il y a ces difficultés à ne
pas trop restreindre mais il y a de
l'autre
côté des propos notamment j'ai entendu
avec Madame main de où il faut faire
attention c'est que cette liberté n'est
possible ne peut s'exprimer ne peut se
déployer que si elle a l'encadrement qui
permet que les valeurs de la République
soit préservé et je crois que cela tant
dans le domaine de stockage du Big Data
et cetera on peut regarder ce que fait
l'état faut regarder ce que les grands
groupes privés font parce qu'en terme de
collection de données personnelles et de
surveillance de chaque citoyen réduit à
un consommateur c'est très grave ce qui
est en train de se passer vous voyez il
y a 10 débats il y en a pas qu'un mais
en tous les cas nous devons être
absolument les défenseurs de la liberté
d'expression de la liberté de de la
presse mais mais aussi les les
combattants infatigables pour les
valeurs de la République contre le
racisme l'antisémitisme le terrorisme et
les thèses conspirationniste merci mon
chers
collègu la parole est à Madame Eser
bembassa pour 6
minutes
monsieur le président madame la
secrétaire d'État et mes chers collègues
je voudrais en préambule remercier nos
collègues du groupe RDSE d'avoir inscrit
à l'ordre du jour un débat sur le thème
Internet et la loi du 29 juillet 1881
sur la sur la liberté de la
presse les propos tenus sur Internet
suscite dans bien des cas la
stupéfaction et je suis convaincue
que si l'on veut lutter efficacement
contre le racisme l'antisémitisme le
terrorisme et l'homophobie qui gangraine
notre société il est urgent de
s'attaquer à la prolifération des
discours haineux sur la
toile ces discours ces propos qui
rappellent des pages douloureuses de
notre histoire entam jour après jour
notre cohésion républicaine et porte
atteinte au au principes fondateurs de
notre vivre ensemble je veux le
souligner ici et ce sans aucune
ambiguité ces discours ne relèvent pas
d'une rhétorique sans effet sur le réel
ils peuvent engendrer la violence et
parfois entraîner la mort nous en avons
fait la terrible expérience en janvier
dernier ces événements qui ont
bouleversé la France et le monde doivent
assurément nous encourager à agir mais
nous devons au préalable nous poser les
bonne question afin d'opter pour les
solutions les plus efficaces sans
oublier jamais que la liberté
d'expression est
consubstantielle à la démocratie et à
l'état de droit la première
interrogation à laquelle nous
parlementaires ne pouvons nous
soustraire est clair les politiques de
lutte contre les discours aineux sur
Internet actuellement misise en œuvre
sont-elles suffisantes l'arsenal
juridique existant
notamment dans son volet répressive
est-il
effectif au premier rang de ces
dispositifs et au cœur de notre débat se
trouve la loi du 29 juillet
1881 sur la liberté de la presse qui
protège la liberté d'expression et en
défin les limites et qui a été inspiré
par l'article 11 de la Déclaration des
Droits de
l'Homme certes les nouvelles
technologies du Web permettent la
diffusion massive sur les réseaux
sociaux comme Facebook et Twitter de de
discours à haute teneur de haine lesquel
n'avaient pas jusqu'ici leur place dans
les médias traditionnels et dont la
visibilité est bien sûr accrue par leur
effet des
multiplicateurs le groupe écologiste
n'en considère pas moins que ces
infractions doivent continuer à être
soumise à la loi de
1881 s'ils doivent être combattu et
réprimer les abus de la liberté
d'expression présentent une spécificité
telle qu'il ne peuvent y avoir leur
place dans le code pénal une seule
exception à cette règle peut être
envisagée le cas où la simple expression
de haine dévie par exemple vers la
provocation publique aux actes de
terrorisme notamment suivi des faits
c'est la position que nous avons défendu
lors des débats sur le projet de lois
relatif à la lutte contre le terrorisme
et que nous défendons aujourd'hui encore
en revanche si la loi du 29 juillet 1881
est un pilier de notre démocratie il est
certain que son cadre procédural n'est
pas adapté à ce qu'il convient d'appeler
le web 2.0 et sa masse de blogs réseaux
sociaux et autres plateformes de
discussion l'urgence est aujourd'hui
d'améliorer la lisibilité de cette loi
de préciser les notions d'espace public
et d'espace privés de réformer son cadre
procédural c'est notre rôle et même
notre devoir de législateur beaucoup
restent à faire pour que la lutte contre
les discours haineux sur internet ait de
réelles retombées positives en matière
de législation bien entendu mais
également et peut-être surtout en
matière
d'éducation il est est ainsi fondamental
d'enseigner aux plus jeunes à faire la
différence entre ce qui relève du délit
et ce qui relève de la liberté
d'expression et de leur faire comprendre
que si le net doit demeurer un espace de
liberté il n'est pas pour autant un
espace
d'impunité l'exercice de la liberté
d'expression comporte des devoirs et
implique pour
chacun une juste prise de conscience de
ses responsabilités celle notamment d'en
proscrire tout usage susceptible de
ruiner les fondements de l'État de droit
en fait chers collègues il est urgent de
créer comme le demande la CNCDH un ordre
public numérique je voudrais pour
conclure mes chers collègues avoir une
pensée toute particulière pour tous nos
jeunes gay ou lesbiennes victimes
souvent silencieuses d'une homophobie
rampante particulièrement actif sur le
net et qu'il est de nos devoir de
combattre avec autant de détermination
que tous les autres discours de haine je
vous remercie merci ma cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Patrick abat pour
minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
chers collègues la loi du 29 juillet
1881 c'est d'un côté la liberté de la
presse et une information transparente
libre et pluraliste et d'un autre côté
l'assurance du respect des personnes et
des fonctions les publications écrites
véritable outil de démocratie se
voyaient ainsi conforté dans leur
mission les citoyens pouvaient eux avoir
l'assurance d'un large panel de
publication sans censure étatique
préalable ce cependant la loi posait des
limites afin d'assurer le respect et la
dignité pour chaque citoyen mais 55 ans
plus tard l'affaire
salingro jeté au chien pour reprendre
une expression célèbre montrera le
fragile équilibre de cette idéal
démocratique le strict respect de cet
équilibre sur Internet est une nécessité
les navigateurs doivent pouvoir savoir
qui publie l'information qu'il lisent
les éditeurs doivent pouvoir se couvrir
en cas de recours juridique comment les
autorités judiciaires pourraient-elles
statuer dans l'opacité de même un propos
dédictueux peut-être de la
responsabilité de l'auteur du poste du
Modérateur mais l'hébergeur doit en tout
état de cause rester le garant de la
légalité de son site l'ensemble de ces
mesures doit permettre le contrôle
répressif à postériori des publications
mais ne saurait admettre un contrôle
préalable qui risquerait d'instaurer
tout simplement un syème ststème de
censure les lois du 29 juillet 82 et du
30 septembre 86 relatives au nouveaux
médias de masse télévision et radio
n'ont fait en fait que s'adapter à la
société tout en conservant l'esprit de
la loi du 29 juillet 81 et de l'article
11 de la Déclaration des Droits de
l'Homme et du Citoyen Internet se place
dans cette dynamique avec ici
l'émergence de nouveaux acteurs des
acteurs internautes qui reçoivent des
informations et qui produisent de
l'information parmi ces nouveaux acteurs
de l'information je souhaiterais évoquer
ici la question des lanceurs d'alerte
souvent débattu jamais vraiment conclus
le lanceur d'alerte est un acteur
alternatif de la production de
l'information la protection des lanceurs
d'alerte est aujourd'hui un enjeu majeur
tant pour l'activité qu'il mène que pour
ce qu'il représente l'organisation non
gouvernementale Transparency
International considère que seulement
une soixantaine de pays dispose d'une
législation efficace couvrant les
lanceurs d'alertes en France aucune
définition englobante du lanceur
d'alerte n'a été déterminé ainsi seul
des définitions partielles et de toute
évidence perfectible ont été élaborées
couvrant de fait peu de domaines et
surtout protégeant peu les lanceurs
d'alertes des menaces et des
représailles les discussions sur le
secret des affaires tant en France qu'au
sein du Conseil européen viennent
rappeler le chemin qui reste à parcourir
pour pour assurer une réelle liberté
d'expression au sein notre pays dans
l'esprit de la loi du 29 juillet 81 et
de l'article 11 de la Déclaration des
Droits de l'Homme pourtant des avancées
ont pu être constaté grâce à
l'intégration de cinq textes dans notre
législation mais leur caractère
sectoriel empêche une grande partie des
concitoyens d'être couvert efficacement
dans le cadre du lancement d'une alerte
de plus la définition même de l'alerte
et la procédure de lancement à force de
rigidité montre clairement ses limites
exposant de fait les lanceurs d'alertes
à de potentiels représailes il faut
constater que dans la jurisprudence de
la Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
ainsi que dans les standards
internationaux le lanceur d'alerte est
associé à la presse il peut informer
dans la recherche de l'intérêt général
des citoyens et des salariés en
particulier cependant cela a été occulté
dans les textes français à l'exception
notable de la loi du 6 décembre 2013
relative à la lutte contre la fraude
fiscale et la grande délincance
économique et financière dans les autres
domaines les textes de 2007 2012 et 2013
excluent le recours à la presse ainsi
seul les autorités régulatrices ainsi
que la hiérarchie du lseur d'alerte sont
à même d'être informés cette situation
dangereuse pour le lanceur d'alerte
inefficace pour les citoyens et
contraire à l'esprit de la loi sur la
liberté de la presse constitue
aujourd'hui une limite à la liberté de
l'information sous prétexte de lutter
contre l'espionnage
industriel mais aussi peut-être
certainement d'ailleurs par
accommandement à avec l'opacité du monde
des affaires les lanceurs d'alertes
pourrai être considéré comme une bouffée
d'oxygène démocratique il devrait
pouvoir œuvrer dans une légalité
encadrée certes mais émancipatrice et à
ce propos et pour conclure la
législation qui se dessine en matière de
renseignement devra attirer toute notre
vigilance afin de préserver les liberté
individuelle fondamentale des citoyens
la recherche de sécurité fondée sur les
menaces terroristes doit et peut-être
efficace sans remettre en cause les
libertés fondamentales je vous remercie
merci mon cher collègue la parole est à
Monsieur Robert
H
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues en 2012 dans une
décision concernant la Turquie la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme
énonçait je cite qu'Internet est
aujourd'hui devenu l'un des principaux
moyens d'exercice par les individus de
leur droit à la liberté d'expression et
d'information Internet est au cœur de
toutes les interrogations juridiques et
sociales son développement exponentiel
avec des possibilités d'échange infinis
entre internautes du monde entier mêlant
des informations en tout genre a permis
une immense liberté d'expression sur la
toile l'enjeu est colossal si Internet
est un outil formidable de communication
et d'échange
collaboratif il peut malheureusement
aussi se révéler un véritable instrument
don doctrinement de l'opinion
l'efficacité de la propagande
obscurantiste affinée de daesh pour ne
prendre qu'un exemple ou la
prolifération des théories complotistes
à chaque événement qui sappe
littéralement les bases de la confiance
en l'état doivent nous inviter à adapter
notre
droit nous devons nous doter des outils
législatifs pertinent et efficace pour
prendre en compte ce nouveau facteur du
numérique
lors de l'examen de la loi du 13
novembre 2014 relative à la lutte contre
le terrorisme nous avions eu ce débat la
loi de 1881 a montré ses limites face au
nouveaux moyens de communication que
sont les réseaux sociaux les sites
internet les vidéos en ligne cette loi a
procédé au transfert du régime des
délits de provocation au terrorisme et
d'apologie du terrorisme de la loi de
1881 vers le code pénal permettant de
durcir considérablement le régime
applicable à de tels délits par ailleurs
elle a autorisé le blocage administratif
des sites djihadistes il y a quelques
jours ont eu lieu les premiers blocages
il s'agit d'un pas en avant contre le
terrorisme mais d'un petit pas car il
reste encore une longue route pour
contrer cette menace devenue permanente
les biiais de ces blocages
administratifs avaient a été souligné
ils apparaissent avec netteté
aujourd'hui la première conséquence
prévisible de blocage sans décision de
justice est celle-ci les propriétaires
de sites incriminés peuvent se poser en
victime de la censure où commence la
liberté d'expression où s'arrête-t-elle
l'absence de contrôle de ces blocages
par le pouvoir judiciaire est
préjudiciable comme nous l'avions
souligné en novembre dernier par
ailleurs sans compter qu'il existe de
nombreuses manières de contourner ce
blocage accès aux pages en cach
utilisation des des serveurs desns et
systèmes de de nombre domaine alternatif
pour échapper à la redirection des des
fournisseurs d'accès à Internet ou ou
recours et à réseau chiffré j'en passe
le blocage des sites n'a n'a été que
partiel cet opérateurs euh et non des
moindres certains opérateurs et non des
moindres n'ont pas appliqué le
dispositif du gouvernement à ces
difficultés bien connu s'ajoute
immanquablement la publicité faite à ces
sites à cette occasion en France la loi
de 2004 pour la confiance dans
l'économie numérique avait permis de
créer un équilibre dans le cadre d'une
responsabilisation de l'hébergeur ce
dernier n'étant pas responsable par
principes des contenus qui l'éberge il
pouvait le devenir si ayant connaissance
du contenu testement illicite il
n'agissait pas promptement pour les
retirer il est difficile aujourd'hui de
contraindre les hébergeurs de tel sit à
retirer rapidement ses contenus
illicites notamment lorsqu'ils sont
basés à l'étranger aux États-Unis
souvent les hébergeurs se réfugient
derrière la protection du freedom of
speech la liberté d'expression dans sa
conception la plus large du premier
amendement de la Constitution des
États-Unis Twitter a ainsi longtemps
refusé de bloquer ou de censurer des
mots clés antisémites ou homophobes
avant de nouer un partenariat avec des
associations pour tenter de mieux
contrôler ses propos si ce géant du Net
notamment a annoncé des mesures contre
la propagande judaïste et bien les
évolutions de cette conception sont
vraiment à confirmé alors que le groupe
Anonymous a publié récemment une liste
de plus de 9000 comptes Twitter liés à
l'état islamique afin d'exercer une
pression sur cet hébergeur la puissance
publique peut-elle se contenter de se
reposer sur la société civile ne
peut-elle anticiper certaines évolution
reconquérir un pouvoir du moins une
influence sur le cours des choses le
ministre de l'Intérieur Bernard casazenu
doit réunir au mois d'avril les géants
du Net afin de signer des codes de bonne
conduite mais nous pouvons légitimement
nous demander si de telles mesures
seront suffisantes pour indiguer un
mouvement toujours croissant aujourd'hui
Google Facebook Twitter et d'autres
règnent sur la toile mais demain
certainement d'autres apparaîtront se
développeront et ne seront pas associés
à ce code notre société aujourd'hui
rencontre des difficultés tenant à à
l'équilibre fragile entre la
préservation des libertés individuelles
d'un côté et la sécurité de l'autre la
question de la gouvernance d'Internet
est donc à ce titre plus que jamais
lancinante elle touche à la manière
aussi dont nous voulons redéfinir les
contours de la liberté d'expression la
loi de 1881 offre un régime trop
protecteur à cette exaction à ces
exactions et donc une faille pour ceux
qui qui porte atteinte aux valeurs de la
République mais le délit d'apologie du
terrorisme peut devenir contestable oui
contestable et donc dangereux pour les
libertés publiques si son utilisation
n'est pas nettement définie pourrait-on
l'employer quand il s'agit d'un simple
d'une simple contestation sociale de
l'ordre en place ou pourrait-on comme
cela s'est vu dernièrement mettre en
cause un enfant de 8 ans sur la base de
ces infractions de cette infraction en
ignorant par la même les vertus
préventives de l'éducation et de la
construction d'un lien social sur la
d'une confiance réciproque la tendance
naturelle du renforcement de l'arsenal
législatif pour contrer les débordements
de la liberté d'expression ne doivent
pas faire oublier que l'action publique
a vocation à agir en amont et en aval et
doit se faire dans le cadre du respect
des principes du droit sans en arriver à
un patriote h à la française que nous ne
souhaitons absolument pas bien
sûr éducation civisme égalité des
chances voilà les vraies interrogations
que nous posent aujourd'hui les
difficultés rencontrées par la loi de
1881 se poser les bonnes questions c'est
déjà y répondre partiellement merci mon
cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur Alain
Joyandet pour 5
minutes merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
au fond le le thème qui nous rassemble
aujourd'hui Internet et la loi du 29
juillet
1881 sur la liberté de la presse au fond
pose la question est-ce que en fonction
de l'arrivée en en masse et en volume
des informations sur Internet on doit
changer on doit légiférer on doit
prendre de nouveaux textes sur cette loi
avec cette loi de 1881 qu'il faudrait
éventuellement modifier à cause
d'Internet alors moi je je réponds assez
assez franchement non je ne pense pas
qu'il faille changer notre
législation sur la loi sur la presse
parce qu'au fond cette loi qui est déjà
très ancienne et qui s'est effectivement
beaucoup appliqué à la presse écrite a
tout permis aussi bien la liberté
d'expression à laquelle nous sommes très
attachés qu'au respect du droit des
individus je voudrais établir un un
parallèle on a souvent peur de ce qui va
tomber demain matin sur Internet parce
qu'on ne contrôle pas internet dans la
presse écrite c'est à peu près la même
chose au fond parce que le procureur de
la République ne va pas au pied de la
rotative pendant que le journal est en
train de s'imprimer le journal s'imprime
il est distribué si le lendemain il y a
quelque chose de diffamatoire c'est
après qu'on contrôle on contrôle pas à
priori on contrôle à postériori et donc
je vois pas pourquoi avec Internet on
aurait les moyens parce que c'est encore
beaucoup plus difficile de contrôler a
priori ce qui va être publié donc je
vois pas pourquoi nous devrions changer
notre législation parce qu'il y a un
transfert de technologie les choses ne
fonctionnent pas si mal aujourd'hui ça
c'est ma première réflexion deuxième
réflexion au fond la question qui est
posée aussi c'est comment est-ce qu'on
protège avec internet comment est-ce
qu'on protège comment est-ce qu'on met
en avant et comment est-ce qu'on
revalorise le travail des professionnels
parce qu'avec nos médias iitionnel au
moins on avait cette sécurité que le
travail d'informer était fait par des
professionnels aujourd'hui avec Internet
on a beaucoup plus d'amateurs qui
viennent informer entre guillemets la
question pour nous
lecteur internaut c'est comment est-ce
qu'on fait la différence entre les
bonnes informations et les mauvaises et
moi je suis beaucoup plus pour une
traçabilité pour un label pour une façon
de renforcer le travail des
professionnels
plutôt que d'essayer de censurer le
travail de ceux qui sont pas des
professionnels parce que de toute façon
on y arrivera jamais avec cette affaire
totalement mondialisé il y a la question
de la sécurité effectivement et de tous
les événements qui se sont produits
jusqu'à présent qui ont pu être
enclenchés par un certain nombre
d'informations de sites qui posent
problème tous ces sites là moi je pense
qu'il faut essayer de régler le problème
au plan international et pour moi ça
relève pas des questions qui touchent à
la presse mais plutôt des questions qui
touchent à la sécurité je crois qu'on
aura prochainement un texte sur la
sécurité et à mon avis on est assez
éloigné des questions stricto sensu qui
concerne la presse et puis il y a aussi
un autre élément et d'ailleurs sur la
question de la sécurité je vois pas très
bien comment on fera autrement que de
surveiller en permanence et au-delà
d'une loi qui touche essentiellement à
l'information mais il faudra une
surveillance permanente des sites et ça
ça touche pas directement la loi sur la
presse il y a un autre sujet c'est la
question de la vie publique et de la vie
privée j'en ai entendu beaucoup parler
je pense pas qu'avec la presse écrite on
ait moins de problèmes s'agissant de la
vie publique et de la vie privée il y a
beaucoup de de journaux de presse écrite
qui touche directement à la vie privée
il y a une législation ça se fait
toujours d'ailleurs pas à priori mais à
postériori et là encore avec internet je
ne vois pas en quoi les choses changent
fondamentalement c'est une c'est une
nouvelle culture et je pense c'est une
culture totalement différente on sort
d'une société organisée d'une manière
très verticale avec un petit nombre de
gens qui balançaient de l'information
qui étaitl par la base aujourd'hui on
est dans une société totalement
horizontale où le citoyen envoie de
l'information à d'autres citoyens les
choses sont très différentes et en tout
cas je je trouve que ça serait très
difficile de pouvoir changer notre
législation pour atteindre des objectifs
qui sont encore très flous je pense que
c'est à nous d'encourager le
professionnalisme de trouver une
régulation internationale pour les
questions qui touche à la sécurité et
pour le reste je crois qu'il est urgent
de de d'attendre pour toucher à cette
législation avec des résultats qui me
paraissent
particulièrement incertain et par-dessus
tout je pense qu'il faut protéger notre
liberté d'expression qu'il faut protéger
les professionnels de l'information et
puis le reste je pense qu'il est encore
euh trop tôt pour dire ce qu'il faut
faire en matière de législation et moi
je serais très très prudent à chaque
fois qu'on touche à la législation sur
la presse c'est un petit bout de la
démocratie qu'on touche et par
conséquent c'est un ancien journaliste
modeste qui fait cette
recommandation faisons très très
attention chaque fois qu'on touche à ces
sujets là c'est un petit bout de la
République qu'on touche donc prudence
prudence merci mon cher collègue la
parole est à Madame Sylvie Robert pour 4
minutes bien monsieur le Président
Madame la ministre mes chers collègues
tout d'abord merci au au groupe RDSE
d'avoir permis ce débat effectivement il
est important il est plus que jamais
essentiel cela transparaît à travers vos
propos mais il est aussi très sensible
au premier abord d'ailleurs il pourrait
paraître anachronique de lier internet
ce nouveau monde du 21e siècle et la loi
du 29 juillet 1881 qui date d'un siècle
là où la seule révolution économique et
sociétale qui prévalait était celle de
la révolution industrielle et pourtant à
l'air de la révolution numérique je
crois que la loi du 29 juillet 1881
demeure encore le pilier contre lequel
nous pouvons nous adosser afin de
traiter de la liberté d'expression et de
ses limites car il faut le rappeler si
la liberté d'expression est un droit
absolu elle n'en demeure pas moins comme
toute liberté relative et encadré le
tout est permis divant l'un des frères
kamazov est toujours fatal à l'humanité
ainsi la loi sur la liberté de la presse
a traversé le turbulent siècle des excès
s'ajustant aux évolutions du secteur
comme mutation de la société sa
cohérence sa clarté son équilibre en
font je pense un repère toujours
important à l'heure où les valeurs
démocratiques et nos convictions
profondes dans le progrès social et
civilisationnel sont qu quotidiennement
assaillis par des actes discours de
haine l'appel au meurtrre sur la toile
au nom d'une opinion différente ou même
la destruction du patrimoine universel
culturel en plein désert iraakien
constitue malheureusement encore
aujourd'hui notre quotidien face à ce
déferlement de violence de haine sur la
toile je vous le dis quand même tout
n'est pas permis dans ce climat parfois
délétaire il faut toutefois de mon point
de vue se garder de répliquer à
l'extrémisme par des mesures extrêmes et
rapides la maturité démocratique d'un
état mes chers collègues s'estime aussi
à l'onte de sa capacité à répondre avec
sansfroid avec réflexion avec
pondération et avec retenue c'est
pourquoi et ce n'est qu'un exemple la
future loi sur le renseignement devra
veiller je pense à maintenir un certain
équilibre entre efficacité
opérationnelle et sauvegarde des
libertés fondamentales il me semble donc
qu'au lieu de peut-être vouloir
détricoter le texte de 1881 le moment
est venu de le préserver peut-être de le
renforcer d'ailleurs mais surtout bien
sûr de l'adapter à Internet en effet en
insens Internet et la loi sur la liberté
de la presse sont
inextricablement unis par l'esprit
libertaire qui les caractérise ils sont
avant tout un instrument précieux au
service de l'un des droits de l'homme
les plus précieux en l'occurrence la
liberté de communication des opinions et
des pensées article 11 de la Déclaration
de
1789 cependant face aux solitudes Inter
active aux pseudonymes qui masquent les
véritables identités aux écrans qui
agissent telles des barrières protecties
le sentiment d'impunité sur l'espace web
ou croix et favorise la prolifération de
discours nausé à bond aussi bien que des
forums ou sur les réseaux sociaux dans
ce contexte il serait peut-être opportun
de réfléchir effectivement précisément à
la notion d'ordre public numérique afin
que l'espace internet ne soit plus
synonyme d'impunité pour les individus
tout en étant bien sûr régi par des
considérations englobant l'ensemble des
droits fondamentaux pardà la belle loi
sur la liberté de la presse l'article 62
de la loi pour la confiance dans
l'économie numérique obligeant les
acteurs d'Internet à coopérer avec les
autorités judiciaires et administratives
pour permettre l'identification de
personnes ayant contribué à la création
de contenu illicite doit à terme
s'imposer aux grandes entreprises
américaines qui hébergent des discours
de haine sur leur site et qui
revendiquent l'extranéité juridique eu
égard à leur domiciliation de siège
social le dialogue avec ces hébergeurs
entrepis par le ministère de de
l'intérieur est une première étape vers
la régulation de l'espace internet pour
autant je pense que l'arsenal répressif
ne sera jamais suffisant il faut
s'attaquer aux racines des mots et
toujours s'attacher à l'éducation en
matière de numérique la réflexion
interministérielle doit continuer à
prospérer et à mon sens il serait
bénéfique que le plan numérique qui
verra le jour d'ici 2016 comprenne un
vol les formation des élèves à Internet
afin d'apprendre à impréander cet espace
à exploiter ses sources et les
informations qu'il contient l'objectif
c'est qu'il finalement s'approprie cette
formidable pépinière tout en ayant
conscience de la responsabilité
citoyenne qui est la leheure en
participant à l'expression publique
généralisée les mots ont un sens et
toutes les opinions ne se valent pas
certaines sont même des délis internet
n'est pas une zone de non drroit enfin
pour terminer laissez-moi souligner
l'importance de la responsabilité
éthique et déontologique de certains
journalistes les événements récents et
le traitement de l'information de
certaines chaînes nous le rappelle sans
cesse peut-être mais je m'adresse à
madame la ministre je ne sais pas
faudrait-il pouvoir déconnecter de ce
qui relève de la liberté d'expression de
certains individus de Cell qui
relèverait par exemple des médias c'est
une question en tous les cas pour
terminer on perçoit une fois une fois
encore mes chers collègues que dans dans
tous débat de société les réponses à
donner seront à faire d'équilibre et du
curseur merci merci ma cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur François bonhomme
pour 5 minutes mon cher
collègue monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues la loi du
29 juillet 1881 sur la liberté de la
presse est sans doute une des lois les
plus connues de notre République et pas
seulement parce qu'elle s'affiche sur
les murs pour interdire précisément
l'affichage sur la voie publique elle
est aussi l'une des plus symboliques
puisqu'elle touche aux liberté et
responsabilité de la presse française
imposant un cadre légal à toute
publication on pourrait retracer comme
cela a été fait avant moi les nouveaux
enjeux de cette liberté
d'expression l'enjeu législatif est
d'autant plus important que tout
encadrement de la liberté d'expression
est suspect d'atteinte aux libertés
fondamentales de l'homme chacun doit à
juste titre comme le gislateur faire
preuve de la plus grande prudence et
n'intervenir que d'une main
tremblante d'abord il est important de
raaffirmer que la France sonore d'être
le pays de la liberté d'expression c'est
un principe absolu très normalement
consacré par plusieurs de nos textes
fondamentaux a commencé par l'article 11
de la Déclaration droits de l'homme et
par la Convention européenne des droits
de l'homme HME bien sûr un premier débat
porte sur les exceptions comme autant de
limite à cette liberté
d'expression dernièrement il y a
quelques semaines la loi de novembre
2014 sur la lutte contre le terrorisme a
sanctionner plus durement
l'apologie de celui-ci
mais l'usage d'Internet doit
nécessairement bouleverser notre façon
d'aborder notre attachement à la liberté
d'expression sur le web chacun ici a
développé son intervention sur le thème
internet formidable outil de
communication qui favoriserait les
échanges et rapprocheraiit les individus
et peut-être même les peuples néanmoins
il me semble que l'outil Internet
comporte une ambivalence fondamentale
qui bouleverse notre conception des
choses et cela ne revèle pas forcément
d'une modification législative mais
plutôt relèt d'une dimension
ontologique l'idée même de régulation du
numérique me semble
trompeuse il faut dire que nous sommes
tous victimes d'une certaine illusion
face à
Internet un philosophe bien inspiré
parlait d'inquiétante extase devant la
fascination exercée par internet sur les
esprits qui se piquent de modernité je
prends l'exemple des cinq sites faisant
l'apologie du terrorisme qui ont été
bloqués bien sûr cela est nécessaire
mais il faut bien dire qu'il y a une
forme d'illusion et même dubriss de
croire que l'on peut contrôler la
toile certains experts estiment que ces
nouvelles mesures pour être même
contreproductives en forçant un passage
à la clandestinité vers des technologies
plus difficiles à
surveiller la mesure est donc
contournable puisqu'il est techniquement
facile de reconstituer reconfigurer sa
connexion internet mais plus largement
je parlais tout à l'heure d'illusion
face à Internet cette illusion me semble
précisément de croire qu'il ne s'agit
que d'un outil internet transforme
insidieusement notre rapport au monde et
d'abord c'est la substitution du virtuel
réel c'est la soumission à ses caprices
et à ses humeurs parfois les plus
volages c'est la réduction du temps de
présence Internet se sont aussi et fait
de nous malgré nous des usagers
compulsifs il n'y a qu'à considérer
notre rapport aux informations c'est
l'ordre du bon plaisir qui rencontre qui
ne rencontre aucun frein c'est aussi
l'arrasement de toute hiérarchie des
valeurs et des œuvres car ne nous y
trompons pas internet participe comme
cela a été dit à ce mouvement
d'horizontalité et je suis heureux
madame la ministre de que vous figuriez
ici pour ce débat mais je me demande si
ce n'était pas la ministre de la Culture
que nous aurions dû voir également quand
je vois le processus de disparition des
notions d'auteur et d'œuvres que nous
constatons par l'effet d'internet je me
demande même si c'était pas la ministre
de l'Éducation que nous aurions pu voir
ici sur ces bans quand je vois
l'affaiblissement de l'école et de
l'autorité des professeurs car c'est
bien aussi internet qui produit des
effets considérables qui affaiblissent
l'idée même de médiation et d'autorité
c'est le cas ça a été dit pour les
journalistes hier ils étaient des
médiateurs qui analysaient les faits ils
sont aujourd'hui de plus en plus des
modérateurs au sein de réseaux sociaux
tant les citoyens sont connectés sans
relâche et sont soumis à un flux
permanent
d'information encore que madame la
ministre je vous ai entendu lors d'une
prestation télévisée le samedi soir et
quelques jours évoquer je cite la
République
numérique cette formule relève peut-être
de l'oximort car pour illustrer vos
propos vous avez parl de du plan
numérique à l'école car aujourd'hui
c'est bien connu tout est numérique
c'est notre nouveau totem et quel élu
d'ailleurs ne se glorifie pas d'offrir
des tablettes numériques au collège
comme si c'était la martingal pour
traiter de l'affaiblissement de l'école
et puis vous avez ajouté cela implique
que le prof ne soit plus le sachant je
cite et l'élève l'apprenant il aurait
d'aurs beaucoup à dire sur l'utilisation
de cette nuve langue administrative de
l'éducation nationale qui substitue le
terme professeur à ce nouveau barbarisme
de sachant et le terme d'apprenant au
beau mot d'élève cel un dilon finalement
sur ce mouvement de déliquessence en
tout cas d'horizontalité qui n'épargne
pas même l'école en fait madame la
ministre votre propos est significatif
de ce quiité à l'œuvre de manière
insidieuse c'est qu'Internet affaiblit
aussi toute forme de verticalité et en
premier lieu les différentes
institutions de la République a comenc
par le professeur et l'école le
journaliste et la presse en général et
pas seulement la presse écrite et
voyez-vous même le médecin dont le
diagnostique est aujourd'hui mis en
doute par les patients qui accordent de
plus en plus d'autorité aux sites
médicaux dès lors madame la ministre je
n'ai qu'une seule roquette même j'allais
dire une supplique ne cédez pas à cette
illusion du tout connecté et de la
République numérique je vous remercie
merci mon cher
collègue la parole est à madame la
ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les
Sénateurs merci d'avoir inscrit ce sujet
à l'ordre du jour des travaux du Sénat
merci en particulier à monsieur le
sénateur mzard d'avoir ainsi inscrit et
posé les termes
du débat je tiens à préciser que
mesdames fleurs pèin et Christiane
tobira auraient aussi souhaité être
présente je vais ainsi participer en ma
qualité de secrétaire d'État au
numérique en tentant d'apporter ma
contribution sans doute un peu
influencée par mon passé de juriste et
en tout cas soucieuse d'aborder
sereinement des questions qui ne sont
pas encore forcément toute
arbitré je vous expliquerai d'abord que
la la loi sur la liberté de la presse
c'est une grande loi ensuite que cette
loi elle doit être modernisée et puis
finalement qu'il y a d'autres moyens
aussi de préserver et de protéger nos
concitoyens et la liberté d'expression
sur Internet d'abord l'affirmation de la
liberté d'expression elle figure parmi
les grandes victoires de la Révolution
française elle est le socle de nos
démocraties modernes figure à l'article
11 de la Déclaration des droit de
l'homme et du citoyen la libre
communication des pensées et des
opinions est un des droits les plus
précieux de l'homme tout citoyen peut
donc parler écrire imprimer librement
sauf à répondre à l'abus de cette
liberté dans les cas déterminé par la
loi la liberté de la presse a quant à
elle dû attendre un siècle de plus pour
être reconnu et consacré par une loi en
1881 et tout comme la liberté
d'expression cette liberté de la presse
elle n'est pas
absolu mais comme c'est le cas pour
toutes les grandes lois à mon sens le
législateur de 1881 a recherché un point
d'équilibre entre le principe de la
liberté d'expression et la répression
des abus dans l'exercice de cette
liberté une société démocratique ne peut
pas condamner pénalement l'usage de la
parole sans dresser de solide garanti
contre la censure c'est bien là l'esprit
de cette loi de 1881 qui soumet la
procédure à des conditions qui la
rendent à la fois complexe c'est vrai et
protectrice des personnes poursuivies
avec par exemple des délais de
prescription plus courts un encadrement
des conditions de saisine du tribunal
une exclusion de la procédure de
comparition immédiate et sous son angle
pénal parce que cette loi a bien sûr un
angle pénal et et bien le texte propose
d'aborder la question de la liberté de
la presse avec toutes les garanties que
peuvent offrir les règles de procédure
pénale l'infraction de presse par
exemple doit être interprétée
strictement les débats sont orau les
témoins auditionnés et primotés et
donnés au droits de la défense cette loi
de 1881
elle a connu plus de 120 ans de
jurisprudence c'est un texte qui a fait
s preuves à l'épreuve de la pratique et
comme d'autres grandes lois
républicaines je pense par exemple même
si le parallèle n'est pas forcément
évident à la loi sur la laïcité et bien
je crois que c'est une loi qui a su
s'adapter alors en 2015 est-ce toujours
le cas avec Internet on sait que l'élan
démocratique peut
simplifier peut trouver une case de
résonance mondiale la participation des
citoyens à la vie de la cité elle est
désormais non pas virtuelle mais bien
réelle avec des contributions qui
expriment des opinions sur des blogs sur
les réseaux sociaux sur les forums de
discussion les sites de notation et de
recommandation internet et les réseaux
sociaux changent la donne du monde dans
lequel nous vivons cela peut-être pour
le meilleur et il faut le souligner par
parce qu'Internet est un véritable outil
d'émancipation les révolutions du
printemps arabe n'auraient jamais eu
lieu sans les réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui grâce au numérique chacun
peut se former et apprendre avec une
facilité sans pareil dans l'histoire de
l'humanité on l'oublie parfois mais on n
jamais autant lu et écrit qu'à notre
époque l'accès au savoir s
démocratisé alors internet qui est un
outil c'est aussi l'outil du pire et
malheureusement nous l'avons connu tout
récemment dans notre pays alors ce pire
doit-il signer le glat de la loi de
1881 jusqu'à présent des réponses à ces
tranché avaient permis la sanction des
propos aux et non internet n'est pas une
zone de non droit cependant les exemples
de condamnations sont resté relativement
peu nombreux j'en citerai certains une
condamnation à 10000 € d'amende par
exemple du responsable d'un blog sur
lequel des commentaires racistes ont été
publiés une condamnation à 40 heur de
travaux d'intérêt général et à 300 €
d'amende de deux jeunes qui avaient créé
une page Facebook appelant à
l'euthanasie d'un jeune handicapé une
condamnation à 1000 € d'amende pour une
personne ayant créé une fausse page via
Deo qui était diffamatoire au nom de
quelqu'un d'autre mais alors pourquoi ce
sentiment d'impunité pourquoi cette
impression qu'aujourd'hui tout peut-être
dit et écrit sur les réseaux sociaux que
à moins de se lancer dans des combats
judiciaires onéreux et long et bien
justice ne peut pas être
rendue je crois que cette loi de 1881
elle doit être réformée à l'heure du
numérique au là du travail législatif le
gouvernement prépare un plan de lutte
contre le racisme qui abordera en partie
ce sujet et la Commission nationale
consultative des droits de l'homme une
autorité administrative indépendante
vient aussi de me rendre un avis sur la
lutte contre les discours de la haine
sur Internet dans cet avis la Commission
considère qu'un certain nombre de
dispositions procédurales incluses dans
la loi de 1881 son sont aujourd'hui
manifestement décalage avec l'expression
publique sur Internet et la Commission
recommande un certain nombre
d'amélioration j'en citerai certaines
ici qui ont particulièrement retenu mon
attention qui et qui feront l'objet d'un
travail
intergouvernemental d'abord préciser et
actualiser les notion d'espace public et
d'espace privé dans le web
ensuite envisager la numérisation des
procédures les les assignations les
significations les dépôts de plantes
peuvent et doivent se faire en ligne il
faut simplifier et faciliter les
procédures de référé par la création
pourquoi pas d'un référé numérique
aujourd'hui grâce aux outils numériques
la justice peut-être plus accessible à
tous plus rapide et plus efficace il
faudrait aussi prévoir un droit de
réponse effectif sur Internet au profil
des associations
antiracistes et puis énoncer dans la loi
le pouvoir du juge d'ordonner la
suspension d'un compte utilisateur et
non pas d'un simple message qui
aujourd'hui permet à des auteurs de
propos très extrême de se voir annuler
un message pour le republier le
lendemain je souhaiterais que nous
initions une réflexion sur la pertinence
d'augmenter d' harmoniser les délais de
prescription enfin il faudrait envisager
la possibilité d'engager la
responsabilité pénale des personnes
morales en dehors des seuls organes de
presse donc ces propositions sont à
l'étude je tiens à ce qu'elles soit
expertisée pour que je puisse en accord
avec le ministère de la Culture et avec
la Chancellerie retenir celle qui nous
paraissent apporter des solutions
satisfaisantes pour éventuellement les
les inclure dans le projet de loi
numérique en cours de préparation à
l'heure actuelle la Chancellerie relève
deux blocage majeur engendrés par
l'application de la loi de 1881 dans la
sphère numérique le premier de ces
blocages c'est celui de la
requalification des faits si un
plaignant lorsqu'il porte plainte a mal
qualifié les faits il parle par exemple
de diffamation plus ô d'injure et bien
le tribunal ne pourra pas requalifier
les faits et l'action en justice ne
pourra pas
prospérer le deuxème problème identifié
par la Chancellerie c'est celui de la
trop grande complexité de la procédure
de cisine des tribunaux le réquisitoire
à fin d'information et la citation
directe du plignant sont soumis à des
règles trop stricte par exemple il faut
que le plignant non seulement qualifie
correctement les faits mais mentionne
dans sa plante le numéro des articles de
loi même des des alinéas applicables au
fait qu'il concerne et la violation de
l'une seule de ces obligations
procédurales elle est sanctionnée par la
nullité et puis la réalité il faut le
dire c'est qu'il n'y a il y a très peu
de poursuite pénale à la suite de
signalement fait d'abord par les
utilisateurs eux-mêmes ensuite par les
plateformes numériques et puis ensuite
par la plateforme Faros qui traite ces
demandes de signalement les transmet
éventuellement au procureur de la
République qui aujourd'hui ne dispose ni
de la formation ni des moyens pour
traiter un contentieux de masse et il
est bien là le problème c'est que il
suffit de voir ce qui s'est passé au
lendemain des attentats qui ont
profondément heurté notre pays ce sont
des dizaines de milliers de signalements
qui étaient transmis chaque jour à la
plateforme Faros composée d'une petite
quinzaine d'officiers de police en
charge de traiter ces
faits on voit bien que aujourd'hui
l'expression publique généralisée à
l'heure d'Internet elle n'est plus
filtrée exclusivement en amont par des
médias professionnels responsabilisés et
soumis à un encadrement déontologique
d'ailleurs les sénateurs assouin et abat
ont eu raison d'insister dans ce
contexte sur la protection des
journalistes et sur la question des
lanceurs
d'alerte vous l'aurez compris je
considère pour ma part qu'il est temps
de réformer cette grande loi de 1881
sans pour autant remettre en cause son
esprit et son équilibre il s'agit
finalement de la moderniser de la
numériser j'ai d'ailleurs le sentiment
man que c'est l'esprit qui est partagé
par les sénateurs qui se sont exprimés
cet après-midi je pense en particulier
au sénateur
jeyandet
j'apprécie une formulation juridique qui
a été avancée par mesdames les
sénatrices Benbassa et Robert celle d'un
ordre public numérique effectivement la
question de l'ordre public cet ensemble
de lois applica
au-dessus du socle
juridique classique et bien pourrait
inclure une dimension
numérique et on peut effectivement citer
outre la lutte contre les propos
racistes les propos
antisémites l'importance de lutter au
quotidien contre les expressions
homophobes très et trop présentes sur
internet et les réseaux sociaux mais
cette loi de 1881 elle n'est pas elle ne
doit pas être le seul moyen de lutter
contre les discours de haine sur
internet il existe d'autres recours et
d'autres outils j'ai échangé avec les
représentants des plateformes numériques
avec les modérateurs privés les
policiers de Faros les magistrats si
nous arrivons à peu près à trouver un
mode de coopération avec les plateformes
avec ces géants de l'Internet il reste
que certaines d'entre elles ne répondent
pas au très peu aux sollicitations des
enquêteurs je pense à Twitter par
exemple qui peut êre en dehors des cas
hautement sensibles politiquement
jusqu'à 8 mois pour répondre aux
sollicitations d'enquêteur de police
français pour des données de connexion
en cas d'injure raciste sur
internet je pense également à ces
policiers qui sont contraints de faire
leur requête en anglais auprès des
plateformes américaines dont le siège se
situe aux États-Unis beaucoup
d'entreprises continuent à se réfugier
derrière l'application de leur loi
nationale pour ne pas intervenir de
manière proactive ils appliquent ainsi
les critère de la loi américaine sur le
premier
amendement concernant le racisme exprimé
mais
paradoxalement interdis la publication
de d'un tableau comme L'Origine du monde
de Courbet qui heurte certaines
sensibilités on le voit bien et monsieur
le sénateur Robert Hu l'a souligné il
faut certainement réformer l'article 6
de la loi sur la confiance dans
l'économie numérique afin d'imposer
notre loi territoriale à tout opérateur
étranger qui s'adresse à un public
français et ne pas le faire uniquement
sous l'angle jurisprudentiel sous
l'angle de la sanction des clauses
abusive en droit de la consommation il
ne s'agit pas pour autant et monsieur le
sénateur mzard a lui aussi raison de le
souligner de privatiser la justice
française mais bien de responsabiliser
l'ensemble des acteurs qui sont
concernés il est pour cela urgent
d'ouvrir un dialogue permanent avec les
plateformes étrangères pour établir des
règles communes et acceptter de tous et
pour cela il faut créer en France un
espace de dialogue non pas dans la
silicone vallée oui madame Morin de les
grandes plateformes doivent être plus
collaboratifes elles doivent faciliter
le retrait des propos et l'action de la
police et de la justice en
France